allí se muestra el gráfico de la función fc
continuación
puede ser valor de entrada para otros de
menos 5 para cualquier líder de equipo y
igualado el 95 2mm efe que tenemos es
nosotros ex convictos elegimos horizontal
el ex benfica hoy y en el sur
tenemos en la grafica tfd ex y por ejemplo
podemos observar que cuando los equipos y
es igual a un nodo nos dice que el valor de r
equipos cuando es igual a la onu es
igual a un valor de 1 en el mrg también podemos
mira que cuando sea equivalente y de equipos
ballet 5 y también podemos ver que cuando
equivalente en m
equipos de ballet fn 6
cual es el valor de la entrada al resto de
menos 5 para él que los equipos del FMI
igual a efe - cinco años cuando los equipos
- 5 de los equipos gráficos de valor r cuatro
valor fd - 5 y 5 a 4 y donde más
ocurre a la derecha
el valor es 4 y casi entrada que producen
valió equipos para los que es
de equipos y 54 kgfm 4 y si gira 4
también cuando es esto
guard 4 anunció que uno toma el mismo valor
que cuando esto es igual a menos 5
entonces tenemos equipos iguales a cuatro
orina